[Music]
robert is in modesto california hi
robert welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um
actually i want to listen to your
podcast maybe three times since we
started this week wow i'm surprised i
actually got you to talk to me welcome
to the gang man
welcome in brother
tell me about two months now that i
needed to listen to you
um we're kind of you know wiper i don't
know if we're on the same page here
she's 48 i'm 54 i make a hundred
thousand a year
just over that um as a paramedic um here
in california
and we are three hundred thousand
dollars up on equity in our house
i have about 600 000 and 401k
75 000 in cars and um
about 30 000 in debt that's a student
loan and a credit card
my wife wants to go to a larger home
because we are
small home four of us here 19 year old
15 year old me and the wife and we're
just running out of room here she wants
to go to a larger home to me that's
a larger payment
a little less stress on on us space wise
a little more stress on his financial
life she advises if i do the ramsay
thing
then uh you know
we'll find the money type of stuff is it
a bad idea to go to a larger home
i'm sorry the last part about the ramsey
thing say that again
she says if we start doing the seven
steps and doing the ramsay method that
it um it'll all work out that the
that the the more payment is not going
to be that big a deal because we'll find
the money somewhere else the baby steps
aren't pixie dust brother yeah the
problem is the problem is that the the
ramsey thing is going to cause you to
not go get a home because you have other
debt you've got to clean up before you
talk about doing that
thirty thousand dollars worth
okay you don't move up and home till you
get that mess cleaned up
the the consumer debt that you've got
right and you're running out of room in
your house you got a 19 year old that
[ __ ] will probably be taken off soon he
got a 15 year old that's just got a
couple of years left i mean this sounds
rather relatively temporary right
yeah you were running out of room 10
years ago
now you're not running out of room now
they're running out of the house
yeah we've been in this house for 20
years that sounds like more of the issue
than the space issue because y'all want
to go do something i don't mind you all
moving to a different home even a more
expensive home i would not do it because
you're running out of room because your
kids are about to leave in an eye blink
uh i'm with john on that i would not do
it until you get your debts paid off
that you have other than the house
um and then that would entail that you
are working the ramsey baby steps that
you have your fully funded emergency
fund your debt free except the house and
then when you make the move on the house
your payment is no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay on a 15-year fixed
rate and then we plan to work extra and
pay that house off sooner than 15 years
because that's what people that become
millionaires do
that would be the ramsay plan
not um we're going to move into a higher
house payment and then we're going to
start seven baby steps and that'll make
it work out that's right no lady that is
not the ramsey plan i'm sorry and robert
make sure that you don't have three
hundred thousand dollars of imaginary
equity burning a hole in your pocket
yeah a lot of folks feel like oh my
house is worth this so now i have to go
x y and z because when you sell in an up
market you also have to buy in and
that's right that's right
so hang up
man i'm a hang on to it man that that
itch might not be scratched by just
spending that money that you don't have
yeah so i i
i think we need to redefine why we're
moving you can't be the two kids because
they're not going to be there and say
i've lived here for 20 years i don't do
something else that's great that's okay
that's wonderful that's okay that's not
a bad thing but we're running out of
room that you should have said that 10
years ago that's right because you were
out of room then
if you're gonna use that one it sounds
like y'all if y'all feel like you have a
300 000 blank check and you don't
that's the part i'm worried about
i think she went out to some open houses
and saw some nice cabinets in the
kitchen no
that's never happened at our house
oh geez
it's like i'm just gonna go to the car
lot and look at them that's right at the
bentley lot i'm just gonna go
drive the drive the maserati that's all
i'm gonna do look at it yeah i'm just
gonna drive the new raptor
would you look at that screen
i don't know how people make it without
a screen that size
yeah it's uh we all do this is what
we're saying not just your wife but i
think she uh i i might accuse sharon
ramsey of doing similar things like she
goes to some friend's house or to an
open house i'm just going to stop by and
look i want to see what people are doing
in kitchens these days suddenly the
ramseys are like oh
or we're tearing the whole freaking
kitchen out yeah and which usually means
that 24 months after we do that we're
moving then you're moving but yeah so
yeah
this is a this is an ailment that is
common to lots of households robert this
is the ramsay show